Cómo se explica la decisión del
presidente Turco erdogan en este mismo
momento
bueno es una posición digamos de Clara
claro oportunismo político de parte del
hogar el dogán puede en este momento
jugar sus cartas en base a los intereses
que Turquía ha venido proclamando como
país que quiere ingresar a la Unión
Europea es una de las condiciones que
que impuso aparte de que
comprometió a Suecia a que eso decía
fuese diligente en los intereses de
Turquía en la ante Bruselas Así que
erdogan está jugando muy bien las basas
geopolíticas aprovechando la situación
que hay con la guerra en Ucrania y Iván
aparte de la integración de Suecia a la
otan otro punto de la Cumbre de vilna es
cómo seguir apoyando a Ucrania vaiden
dijo a la cadena 100 en que kiev todavía
no puede entrar a la alianza le preguntó
si esta es una opinión mayoritaria
dentro de la otan
bueno
exceptuando Hungría y Turquía los demás
países miembros de la otan favorecían el
el ingreso de de nuevos aliados en el
caso de
de Ucrania
los propios requisitos para pertenecer a
la otan no le permiten a un país que se
encuentre bajo un conflicto bélico ser
parte de la alianza atlántica que desde
1949 fue creada para que cualquier
ataque a uno de sus miembros sea
considerado como un ataque a todos los
miembros entonces
de ahí se derivaría una situación
también muy escabrosa porque Ucrania se
encuentra en enfrentamientos contra
Rusia lo cual obligaría a los demás
miembros de la alianza a tener que
defenderle y volviendo al tema de Suecia
le preguntó Qué importancia tendrá para
la propia alianza que ahora la propia
otan
bueno algo que
marca un hito dentro de la historia de
la otan es que un país como Suecia que
siempre tuvo buenas relaciones con con
Rusia
entra dentro del ámbito de la otan pero
que también la otan está rediseñando lo
que sería una estrategia para tener una
especie de cordón sanitario con Rusia es
decir estamos ante un giro copernicano
en cuanto a la política de la otan
contra contra Rusia y en este caso
Suecia también Finlandia forman parte de
de esta digamos nueva dimensión a la
cual Una institución que como señalara
en su momento el presidente francés
Manuel macron estaba muerta
cerebralmente hablando incluso Trump
también la vio por muerto